begin unfortunately with terrible and
breaking news from Mexico where at least
nine Americans including six children
were killed in an ambush video of the
aftermath shows a burned-out vehicle
targeted in the attack family members of
the victims tell CBS News that they do
believe that a drug cartel is behind
this ambush it happened yesterday about
100 miles south of the us-mexico border
the victims who were all women and
children were in a convoy taking some of
them to a wedding they were members of a
Mormon group based in northern Mexico
the family says the FBI is now part of
the investigation
Jericka Duncan is following this
disturbing and developing story drink oh
good morning so what more do we know you
know there's still so many questions and
this just happened last night
authorities in Mexico say they've
deployed members of their Army National
Guard and state police to investigate
the victims all left their community at
the same time in three separate cars
some were traveling back to the United
States some to the neighboring town of
LeBaron for a wedding when suddenly they
were struck by a hail of gunfire so
severe that one of the cars exploded
this is for the record
neaten for my grandchildren Herbert shut
up in a video posted to Facebook you can
see the aftermath of the attack the
scorched SUV that apparently contained
the burnt bodies of Maria ronita Miller
and four of her seven children it's
unclear if they were specifically
targeted the victims reportedly all
belonged to a decades-old Mormon
community based in northern Mexico the
youngest victims were twin babies just
seven months old
some of the children miraculously
survived the ambush but sustained
gunshot wounds they were found by family
members relatives say five remain in the
hospital I was so angry Trish clothes is
the aunt of victim Donna ray Langford
start thinking positive and praying at
the same time that we were all
devastated and very emotional
and did something that you can't explain
how there's evil people in this world
that keep something like that some
relatives say they believe the women and
children were not the intended targets
of the cartels and that this was a case
of mistaken identity amazing we oriented
people they're giving they're always
looking out for others they're an
incredible group of people one family
member we spoke to says the children who
survived are in the process of being
brought to the United States for medical
treatment this morning the US ambassador
to Mexico says they are following the
situation very closely it's hard to wrap
your brain around what we just saw so
pain in the grandfather's voice exactly
all right Joe Rica thank you very much